Recently I took a job working at a camp with at risk boys were out.
Well there I will live and work as a counselor and a house with the kids.
Any advice for working with young people with behavioral issues?
Okay.
Uh,
yeah.
Okay.
It depends on what the behavioral issues are.
So I don't know what our risk meets,
but I,
so I,
I can't be too specific.
But what I can tell you is that almost nothing beats listening.
You know,
like take a kid for a walk,
let him talk.
Like listen to them,
ask them questions.
You know,
because most disturbed people,
and maybe even most people don't actually have anyone they can talk to and they
need to talk first of all,
to find out that someone actually cares enough to listen.
So it's sort of like a validation of the fact that they exist and second so that
they can sort out their own thoughts.
So as a beginning counselor,
the best thing you can do is listen.
You don't want to give advice really.
You know,
because what you want,
you can ask questions that might lead someone in an advisable direction.
But the problem with giving advice is that people are much more likely to
remember something and to implement it if they've thought it up in their own
words.
I think that actually produces a kind of neurological transformation.
The idea has to be in gendered from within.
It's one of the prime dicta of,
of psychoanalytic theory for example.
And I think it's a really good one.
So,
uh,
yeah,
when and with regards,
so Brendan Trista says trippy snakes and retinas.
Yeah.
Like it's really specific.
So this woman named,
um,
okay.
No,
I probably can't remember her name.
Me and he either she,
she wrote a book about trees and serpents.
Uh,
she's a UCLA professor.
Um,
the fruit,
the tree and the serpent,
I think it's called.
She showed quite clearly that not only do our retinas say directly detects
snakes,
but they do a better job in the bottom half of the retina.
And that we're really good at detecting the a camouflage patterns that are
characteristic of snakes to snakes have these like diamond patterns,
which are very,
very rare.
And we have specialized circuitry for detecting those.
And there was recent research conducted that showed that children six months old
who had never been exposed to anything,
even resembling a snake,
had an automatic response to snakes.
And so it actually seems to be innate,
not just,
uh,
not just easily learned.
So that's really quite interesting.